we had make out my heart right now feels
like I just drank 30 espressos we had
Blake down since I got down here like
I've done everything wrong like that
stops well and we had Hannah what are
you doing wow this was great this is
your bachelor in paradise season six
episode to recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses and Rose say hi everybody
I'm Lauren Zima and I'm so sorry that
I'm already so obsessed with bachelor in
paradise but man oh man things are
kicking off and they are not slowing
down hi guys
[Music]
I'm quite tired but I had to vlog of
course because of the Blake Kaelin
situation bachelor nation never stops
does that we watched this explosive
second episode of bachelor in paradise
and Blake releases alleged text messages
between allegedly him and Kaelin about
their hookup now Caitlyn has made some
big accusations about Blake calling him
basically a bad guy and saying that he
was trying to hide things and silenced
her and these text messages Blake said
he had to release to clear his name
because he says he didn't try to silence
Kailyn and you know that perhaps they
were seemingly on the same page about
things now I do think the Blake seemed
quite blindsided when Kaylin came at him
in the episode and was upset at the end
of the day this is becoming quite a
he-said she-said and it's quite messy
and i think it's a lesson in being on
the same page with people when you hook
up with them or have a relationship with
them and also you know nobody should lie
when going into a reality show it seems
like quite a dangerous thing to do
because in some form of different truths
come out but look Blake and Kaylin are
both humans and I think that they both
would change things that they did
probably so let's remember that let's
not attack and I think there's more to
come soon just keep drinking responsibly
and am i wearing the same dress that I
wore for yesterday's episode the answer
is yes I am cheap and I don't spend a
lot on clothes I got this on Amazon and
I decided to wear it again and the
justification in my mind was it's the
same week so it's cool I really did
everything I could think of it so it's
hard when there's two episodes a week I
can't be always fighting these two
outfits okay and the rosies fixing
everything let's get going everybody
episode 2 loved it
what did you think we're diving right in
picking up where we left off with
Christina and her weird why is she doing
it date with Blake so I'll be honest I
was disappointed here I thought
Christina had some kind of master plan
to call Blake ow
but they were kind of like flirting
while she was driving his ATV and then
they sat down to talk and I'll be honest
I found her communication a little
confusing stagecoach
what happened Caitlin was just like a
slap in the face for me I didn't know
what she wanted like to say did she want
an apology I was confused tell me what
you guys thought of the Blake Christina
conversation now that doesn't mean that
I'm excusing Blake and his actions
listen so what happened I'm just gonna
say what happened we were in stagecoach
and it was late and took things too far
and we ended up hooking up but we both
woke up and we were like well you know
we probably got too far at the end of
the day Blake just tell Kristina you're
sorry that'll probably go a long way
Blake seemed to me to be the most upset
about the fact that this conversation
with her Sina was happening on camera
he didn't seem to like his image being
tarnished he seems to want to sweep
everything under the rug and act like
paradise is this whole brand-new world
dude when you hook up with people from
the show you're on that are going on the
same show as you past Conahan talked
about okay it's a reality show yes some
stuff happens in the real world but it's
also a reality show why am I having do
we explain this to you
ap hold obvious why am I talking like
this that's just absolutely
it makes everything better for me if
only you could do that for Blake am i
right because Blake seems lost no things
got away from us but like I'm not in a
relationship with her I'm not really
with anybody and Blake seems troubled
it's been like days ever
and Blake seems concerned I know what to
do
anything ten Blake doesn't seem to see a
way out of this so I don't want to
support Blake a bit because we don't
want anyone to be in this deep of a dark
of a hole that Blake gets to in this
episode we're calling it not a breakdown
it's a breakdown and it's down in the
depths
I will never get tired of that song I'm
sorry if you guys do I love you bye okay
don't make me feel like this disgusting
like secret and turn great that like
you're ashamed of Blake and Christina
are talking in the meantime Kailyn is
overflowing she has just been building
up with this tension about this Blake
and her and Kristina's secret I don't
know why she won't just spill it I I'm
like losing my mind here and then she
ends up spilling over she is confronting
Blake we talked about this we were like
we're gonna be friends and she is crying
it's like acknowledge me like toppled
and Blake is like what do I do
he just keeps apologizing so sorry I
didn't know what did you guys think of
this altercation I did feel a bit for
Blake because he seems kind of
blindsided how did you think it was
gonna go
[Music]
I agree and Kalin was at a level 20 and
Blake was like wait a minute I am down
here at up to he did keep apologizing I
gotta give him credit for that
he seems sorry but tell me what you
thought this is a mess yeah okay so now
Blake literally can't show his face he
pulls his shirt up and kalynn literally
doesn't even know where to go and drink
every time someone says this is not how
they expected paradise to go this isn't
exactly what I expected
take yourself paradise was gonna go well
I would come down here fine it was this
hard also please drink responsibly
but do drink for everyone of Demi's
unbelievable metaphors about Blake's
behavior they were great we have to show
Christina we have Hanna
we have Kailyn are we going from a
square to a Pentagon
back burner isn't understatement because
right now he has like a six-burner stove
I love dummy in other words your mistake
you ever come and go I guess
interestingly wills sums up all of our
feelings on Blake he says quote I feel
for him feel for him but I don't feel
for but I don't feel for him
I don't think paradise isn't necessarily
paradise for him right now Blake how are
you guys feeling I will tell you my
feelings are gonna change by the end of
the episode let's keep going now my
feelings are already changing because
we're learning that apparently he just
told Kristina that he hooked up with
Kailyn the night after her just a few
days before they went to paradise anyone
she told me like a week ago if I had a
shirt
I'd pull it up over my face that's hard
to excuse Blake stagecoach this music
festival where this all seemingly went
down you know I did a bunch of
journalistic investigating aka
a point zero five second go --gel it was
in April paradise built in June I told
her how many times in this franchise
we'll guys get in trouble because they
don't give someone a call
pick up the phone it's like this is a
hurricane horsemen but inside that
hurricane is a tornado and underneath
that tornado is a tsunami that is
brewing and holding it all up all
together is a forest fire burning the
water and heating it and some kind of
godly event is happening and this is a
natural occurrence like we've never seen
we thought climate change was bad okay
this is insane man so we've got to keep
moving on and so does Blake but Willy
I'm not sure he's Blake okay like he is
clutching his chest is he literally
having a heart attack I'm concerned
ABC always Blake be concerning us
I wrote down this has to be the quickest
downfall in paradise' history but more
is happening other than the great Blake
bombing Will's kisses Hannah and I don't
like that I didn't like that you guys
ain't just like Dylan so much just go be
me Dylan I won't do it Wow am i falling
for Dylan faster than I fell for Tyler's
seat paradise does crazy thanks to you
doing ASMR with this palm tree to calm
down
okay but it's about to go on a date with
Nicole but I have some doubts about
clays intentions for sure other stuff is
happening clay is getting some criticism
but the thing is bleak already looks so
bad but I don't know how much I care
about the clay Angela thing right what
do you guys think
are you questioning clay whereas
Annalise overreacting so we are moving
at the speed of light through the sky we
are already getting literal fireworks
for clan Nicole do we like him as a
couple take yourself paradise was gonna
go my family I'm friend of the lake it's
gonna be really hard to see my that's
like what are you going to hiding like
is now like worried about his entire
life and his family and his future and
he doesn't seem to see a reason to go on
ten someone do a wellness check on Blake
is he okay ABC always be checking on
Blake I just like I want your be fixed
and I want us to be fun actually
by the way Kaelyn still talking about
Blake and it's that girl I just want you
to move on now for yourself you've been
in paradise for several days now just
move on from Blake because if he treated
you badly he's not worth your time so
then she does move on yes you may
kind of with camp do we like that I
don't like but drink every time someone
makes out this episode they know that
rose ceremony is coming and they want to
get that rose I think you're awesome
cheers then JPJ is kissing by the way
John Paul Jones was never shown kissing
Hannah on camera so we've never seen
John Bolton I was making out with
anybody before what a milestone I just
spilled not vomit like John Paul Jones
is about to do talk to you guys it's
coming cheers to John Paul Jones
what is this so these are my little taco
tastings John Paul Jones goes from
kissing to vomiting courtesy of Jane
who's kind of like kooky and adorable
she went home one night one of Cole's
and season I don't know whatever her
deal is she's funny but what's not funny
is us hearing the sound of John Paul
Jones vomiting OH
Jane thank you so much no don't even
thank me is he throwing up
I'm trying to make out with JPJ tonight
he's been vomiting I was horrified I
don't want to hear that I don't like I
don't like that I don't like that
littling though how did you guys feel
sick
I'm really sorry Jade John Paul Jones
continues to be the kindest and most
humble human alive while he is throwing
up he is thanking people and comforting
them are you kidding me who do you guys
want to see jvj end up with like who
deserves him it's hard to it's hard to
picture maybe Jane and John Paul Jones
shouldn't be together she just keeps
saying wacky crap she says I'm
responsible for someone puking their
brains up that just endured my like
ability to like do my best tonight she's
like such a weird moment drink every
time someone's crying
viviana is crying she just can't get a
break
like someone loved it be honest she's a
cool girl Will's is crying he can't get
a break either these poor veterans
they're not doing well okay and then my
opinion on Blake is cemented I think the
Blake drama is just getting started
things aren't going well for Blake Blake
took Taoiseach on that date and she
doesn't seem that into him anymore
I don't want it I'm not like trying to
get a pretty rose she says she won't
take his rules
yikes do you feel better tonight I do I
do now I don't want to talk to you yeah
so Blake decides the woman he could have
taken on the date and we didn't want to
Hannah he's gonna copper I made some
mistakes along the way
I know that and like you're the reason
I'm here
okay no I think Blake's a player what do
you guys think I mean he's always been
lovely to me but I'm questioning his
behavior here definitively I love your
dress run away
also is wake just spiraling is he just
totally freaked out by the situation
doesn't know what to do doesn't know how
to fix it I think now you put up walls
and can I blame you no no no one's
telling him how to fix it so he is on a
downward spiral in the tornado hurricane
tsunami hurricane horse and Blake down
somebody throw them a life raft
why did Hanna kiss Blake should she have
kissed Blake I say girl shake it off
[Applause]
but remember this is only our first
group of contestants then we get the
trailer for next week and Jordan is
coming
Jordan and Big Mike is coming and he's
kissing Kaitlyn oh and Hanna is still in
to play no blank tacos from Manos mucho
picante and for the second episode in a
row John Paul Jones is the end credits
you guys is John Paul Jones gonna be the
end credits of every episode this season
of Bachelor paradise rightfully so drink
for every time John Paul Jones is in the
end credits did appreciate you bro
looking sexy man I've been killing
myself in the gym
not almost paradise it is this has been
a strong start to say the least tell me
what you guys are thinking of this
season so far are you in are you out are
you in the hurricane are you on the
shore tell me what you think I love you
so much
can you so much for watching by the way
I'm on Cameo if you want a personal
message to you you can find me on that
app and I adore you I promise I'll wear
a different outfit next week bye e Wow
I'm now right three years in a my okay
[Music]